Okay.
Today we have a second in an installment of
Trumpists whose mind you can't change a fourth.
Today's voicemail segment.
The voicemail number of course is two one
nine two, David P. yesterday we had one example,
a, a woman, a young woman, or I don't know
what age she was, a woman, uh, who made it
clear that it's not a good strategy to go
and try to convince Trump is to change their
mind.
That's not how we're going to win 2020.
I have another example of that for you today.
Take a listen to this.
Are you guys gonna do, once the truth comes
out and all your liberal lies and stuff are
made known, what are you guys gonna do?
Right?
You guys gonna root for when all the bad guys
are locked up.
When, uh, when Obama was in Clinton's and
bushes, all the deep Staters are locked up.
What are you guys gonna do then?
He's going to pay your bills.
There's going, you know what I'm saying?
You guys better get on the right side of the
outside of the reality.
Guys, I'm telling you, you're on the wrong
side of reality.
Yeah.
So listen, as far as paying bills, I've said
before, um, you know, Trump in office has
been good for, for the show in terms of the
business of the show.
It's been terrible for the country and I still
prioritize the country over the show.
I can assure you that if circumstances in
the United States lead to Barack Obama, Hillary
Clinton, and George W. Bush being in prison,
I think the show will be doing just fine.
But of course, you know, deep state conspiracies,
all of this stuff, we can't talk these folks
out of the worldview that they've adopted,
not in any sensible amount of time.
So the focus must be, the focus has to be
get the vote out from people that are on our
side already.
Make sure they don't stay home.
And let's try to improve the country that
way.
Because arguing with folks like that, and
the person called in yesterday, it's an exercise
in futility.
It's a, it's, it's simply not worth it.
It's not worth our time.
We can get way more people to vote before
we can get one of these folks to change their
mind.
On today's bonus show.
George Papadopoulos is running for Congress
and he announced it where of course on Fox
and friends.
We will talk about that T-Mobile has a trademark
on the color magenta and is demanding that
an insurance company stop using that particular
Hugh.
We will discuss that and the limits of intellectual
property also may be good news.
Donald Trump has signed an animal cruelty
bill into law.
Interesting.
When in the video I showed you earlier of
Trump with a dog, he seemed to have absolutely
no affection or empathy for the dog whatsoever,
in fact seemed to want nothing to do with
the dog despite clock calling the dog.
Brilliant and extremely smart.
We will talk about the animal cruelty bill.
On today's bonus show.
How do you get access to the bonus show?
It's very easy.
Sign up for a membership@joinpacmandotcombecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show.
You can also get on our mailing list@davidpakman.com
and this Friday, black Friday.
Everybody on our mailing list.
We'll get an email with a one time use coupon
code for an obscene discount off of a David
Pakman show membership.
So if you want to sign up, but you want the
best membership discount of the year, just
get on our newsletter@davidpakman.com and
Friday.
I would guess early afternoon you will find
in your email inbox a very special one day,
only one time use code for a discounted David
Pakman show membership.
In the meantime, we will talk to you on the
bonus show today.
Morrow, the chest showdown between producer
Pat and me will take place.
We have all been preparing.
I've been doing, I've been working on my lats
actually to prepare for the chess match.
More on that tomorrow though, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.